[Music]
Kenyon's
[Music]
now that she touched um
[Music]
Lea Michele issued an apology Wednesday
morning after her Glee co-star Samantha
wear accuse Lea of making her first
television gig a living hell here's what
went down last week Lea tweeted about
the death of George Floyd a 46 year old
man in Minneapolis who died when a
police officer pressed his knee into his
neck for more than eight minutes
the actress wrote George Floyd did not
deserve this this was not an isolated
incident and it must end black lives
matter
several days later Samantha who played
Jane Hayward on eleven episodes of Glee
in 2015
responded to Leah's message writing
remember when you made my first
television gig a living hell cuz I'll
never forget I believe you told everyone
that if you had the opportunity you
would in my wig among other traumatic
microaggressions that made me question a
career in Hollywood and Samantha wasn't
the only one to speak out against Lea
davier Snell who guest-starred in a 2014
episode tweeted girl you wouldn't let me
sit at the table with the other cast
members cuz I didn't belong there
q Lea then on Wednesday without naming
names
Lea referenced Samantha's claims on
Instagram writing that the responses she
received have made her reflect on her
own actions quote I don't remember ever
making this specific statement and I
have never judged others by their
background or color of their skin that's
not really the point what matters is
that I clearly acted in ways which hurt
other people the actress added I
apologized for my behavior and for any
pain which I have caused the 33 year old
who announced she was expecting her
first child with husbands Andy rich in
April noted that preparing to become a
mom has made her want to be a better
person I know I need to keep working to
better myself and take responsibility
for my actions so that I can be a real
role model for my child I know we
haven't spent a lot of time together
this year but I thought that we were
close enough to be honest with each
other
Lea's apology comes after the meal kit
delivery service hellofresh announced on
Tuesday that
they had ended their partnership with
her effective immediately
but this isn't the first time leah has
been the subject of her co-stars
frustrations I need this job back in
2016
Naya Rivera who played Santana Lopez on
Glee spoke to et about her relationship
with Lea Santana and Rachel
hated each other but they also had like
this love-hate sort of relationship and
I feel like that's what we and I had
while we were on the show
[Music]